if you're like me and you thought
Wolfenstein the new order was a pretty
great game then you're in luck more
Wolfenstein is on the way I'm Chris
waters and this is a game spot news
update bethesda softworks announced this
morning that Wolfenstein the old blood
is in development at machine games it's
a standalone prequel to the new order in
which BJ blaskowitz embarks on a
two-part mission deep within Bavaria as
the Nazis stand on the brink of winning
World War 2 in part 1 he busts into to
steal some info and faces off against a
maniacal prison warden named Rudy Jaeger
and in part two he travels to a city
where a Nazi archaeologist named Helga
von shops is exhuming strange artifacts
it's got new weapons new enemy types and
this really nasty takedown situation
ouch the announcement states that the
old blood will be available digitally
for 1999 on May 5th so it doesn't sound
like the two parts are sold or delivered
separately or anything should just be
one package but only time will tell stay
tuned to gamespot com / news for more on
the old blood and be sure to catch
gamespot's coverage from pax east this
weekend we're more gameplay from the old
blood will be revealed happy wolfy times